thank you
[Music]
has anybody here been to Tacoma
Washington yes I have yes I have what's
it like over there I thought it was
Seattle and then they were like no this
is Tacoma I'm like oh what made you
think it was Seattle they were throwing
fish because it was an event it was
called wat Seattle but but it was in
Tacoma yeah I went there too for that
World of Dance yes it is I know my stuff
dude look I'm captain the commuters
Tacoma and I was like it's pretty chill
it's all right is it because it's so
close and it's one of those things where
like like let's say if you're from the
OC and you meet someone in like Nebraska
where are you from you don't say OC
because I'm L.A yeah yeah like that oh
but uh so something remarkable has
happened in Tacoma remarkable you say
highly remarkable and this might be the
only place in the in America that's
having this specific effect right now it
made the new 2024 Tacoma
in the city of Tacoma easy do they make
it there three inches wider on each side
the new 2024 are you they make it there
but the new Tacoma is pretty sick it's
three three inches wide on your side I
don't think they make it there three
inches is that even noticeable no that's
a lot that's a lot
there's a lot
all right it's big a little too much
laughs
who says that why are you guys laughing
so hard
it's noticeable it's super noticeable
three inches is it always is it soft
sometimes it's a little
all right dude what happens in Tacoma
all right what the [__] happened so
Takoma is uh
Tacoma is showing massive results for
reducing crime wow listen you're doing
what are they doing let's move in there
that is
they never turn the lights off right
yeah yeah it's gonna be something pretty
uh music all the time let's do that
stays down 33 murders are down 30
all right assault is down 17.4 sexual
assaults down because nobody lives there
no there's a lot of people went out
three robbery is down 46.4 kick out all
the crimes all the men the men are gone
but who's gonna calculate these stats
these numbers say something
can you do this where you leave you wish
overall crime is down 23.5 over this one
simple trick what was it other cities
hate that yeah what do you think it is
I think they legalized something that
was previously
and then their minds were opened by the
psychedelics shrooms they allow [__]
micro dosing yeah some civilized murders
so it's not illegal
[Music]
holy [__]
for me I'll legalize everything there's
no more crime that is true though if you
legalize it it's not illegal
that's men logic
no solution yeah
what do you think Nick what do you think
they did
I have no [__] idea this is the
problem is it really just one thing not
a couple of things it's one very big
decision yeah come on I need to know
already
legalizing or Tacoma I don't even know
anything about Tacoma but you know what
when I tell you you're gonna go it's
like that but it's one of those things
that no one else is doing they had
harsher punishments no they have a
[__] neighborhood watch
it's got to be something technical dude
it has it's a it's like right there but
um it we're conditioned now because it's
been so long to not think that this is
what it is yeah they have cops
no way they have more cops that's
literally it these are more cops they've
refunded the police oh oh wait what I'm
not for that dude
they refunded the defunded police in
their City
it was like the whole BLM stuff yeah it
started with the BLM oh can you count
why no
no I was just hoping it wasn't it wasn't
he because it wasn't it like wasn't
stuff happening before you know what I
mean like no I want to say yes because I
feel like you're trying to help me but I
don't think so yeah
are you trying to say it was a long time
ago we're tactics it was a long time ago
this is BLM like obviously cops were
already [__] up before BLM that's what
I'm saying yeah like since the 90s
funding yeah but it wasn't pot you know
see yeah thank you so yeah though I
guess it was like it's it's been
simmering before BLM but BLM was created
when and now that's when it's official
on everyone's radar
one of the few Prime targets like were
they the ones that were really heavily
like let's really defund them like yeah
they defunded it in 2020 by 30 million
the department way out of what out of
what 30 million out of 31 million
out of 30 million
yeah yeah it's crazy that um I can't
believe it was that literally just died
and what's crazy is um during that time
I was following a sheriff via nuevas IG
because he was like he's like I think he
was trying to bypass the news because
the news had like a specific narrative
so he would just like post random videos
like he would talk to his IG just to
tell people what was going on and so it
would be like
um uh LASD which is sheriff's department
and LAPD got defunded this much money
and the people that are for it are like
Yay whatever he goes he would go on his
page and he goes okay so these are the
departments in
um in like the sheriff's department we
have like our Harbor division because
they you know they guard the ports they
have like this division cyber security
whatever he goes these ones are the ones
that are actually getting canceled and
it was like the child yeah they're like
child is now gone uh armed robbery is
now gone so it's like
when you look at like when it's actually
like what the itemized things are you're
like I think we need these to keep our
city safe yeah all of it people don't
think like that they think like oh
evenly like well if there's five cops
just just take out one of every five
cops but it doesn't work like that it's
like they look at okay this we're still
trying to keep the city safe here's the
20 departments that we have which is the
one that I I guess we have to lose so
where you have to still guard City Hall
we still have to guard the courts you
know so like the rich people are still
we still have the guard Beverly Hills
right right but like these ones I guess
were do you want to chop off dude they
should have taken out the traffic cops
yeah
[Applause]
hahaha
what's that the ones that write you
tickets on their bikes I'm always back
here
those guys out our brand but that's part
of the funding to pay the cops though
isn't it not the police cops
I don't ever back you up I'm just really
nervous right now okay because
everyone's staring at me like I'm the
[__] oh you're the one standing up
like an [__] you're supposed to back
me up me yeah dude I just got here I
wonder if that's similar to what
happened when when uh California got rid
of all the mental asylums remember oh
yeah oh yeah it's got closing and all
the people that were not well like just
ended up homeless and randomly yeah
those were gnarly too I wonder if that
got cut because people wanted more of
something else and they were like well
it's got to come somewhere yeah maybe
that's how it is a good shot because
yeah when they do fun things
that department tries to have a logical
approach yeah and then so I think when
people are fighting for things they're
usually not issue based it's just like
just sounds cool yeah exactly and then
so when you scream like into the open
like that when it gets received on the
other side
they're not just gonna like oh we'll
we'll just defund ourselves like they're
like okay well that's what they want so
like let's do it so it's never comes out
the way that they were screaming for
proportional decrease yeah like I always
think that there's a simple solution to
a convoluted problem and it's just like
this is not how things work yeah yeah
the public like social media what do you
see in there you just see like the the
general statement you don't see the
specifics or anything like that so
they're like fighting for something but
they don't really know what's gonna
happen you know what I mean yeah yeah it
is pretty crazy I mean imagine this like
that um within a year like you have 127
sexual offenses and then following that
in 92 that's a pretty big drop yeah like
what if you were one of those like ones
that could have been but you know
that's a pretty like that's a great
thing like even one less is awesome I
mean it just sounds like it could be
like duh right like like
if you define something that's put in
place to protect you yes it's corrupt
yes it has its issues or whatever but if
you just scream out to fund and then it
gets defunded it's like but then you
have an emergency what do you do yeah
because it's like you don't want to like
we're also banning guns so it's like
okay you don't have that either so now
like what how do you protect yourself
yeah like who do you go to you're just
gonna people don't think like that
though on Nick hey Nick I can't help
dude
because they've never ran into a
situation for them to think like that
yeah it's very true a lot of the people
that I've heard that were like you gotta
defund the police you look at them and
then you're like
if you've gotten a physical altercation
or someone's trying to rob you or steal
something from your house you'd be
[__] destroyed you're getting wiped
like you've never seen a physical
confrontation in your life and you're
speaking from a point of like high
privilege and saying well even I think
like a woman right like I I I've never
even I've never met one woman that has
never felt unsafe in her life yeah like
I know every single woman has had like
that walk in the night where she like
leaves work late even if she's from
every day baby you know
um and she's like [__] uh I guess I
should I have my [__] mace if I don't
I have a key like we you we try to think
of all these different weapons we can
use just in case Colleen has a weapon
stash everywhere she goes yeah I do she
has a weapon cash in that's horrible
right her inventory is packed what do
you mean I got you yeah
you know I got it I got I got the stuff
brass knuckles everywhere this does come
as sort of a blessing because now that
the police get refunded then they have
to show results because it's like
justify the money being put back that is
like doing a better job overall maybe
because maybe it's more scrutinized and
more sensitive and more like uh yeah
like you're not gonna get away with it
now that's right all the issues that
people were
having you know well the BLM stuff right
like well even before that like I like I
saw it firsthand in my neighborhood with
my dad and my brother where they were
like racially profiled yeah yeah um and
they got pulled over right in front of
my house and these cops were absolute
dogs to my brother and my dad because
like my dad I mean my brother was like
in his teens just a Mexican looking dude
didn't look like a cholo nothing just
like a regular kid and a hot summer day
and then uh they just had them get out
of the car and then they had his hands
they put it on the hood and he was like
whoa this is like really hot yeah and
they're like I don't give a [__] like
you're the one that is that the right
way to handle that [__] it was like pure
harassment and you could argue I think
there's you have a better stronger
argument that these cops and these um
people need more training more resources
more strategies to be able to handle
those situations than less yes right
especially with everything that we've
seen yeah more better training more
consistent training over a longer period
of time yeah but that would require more
funding so it should have been instead
of defund until he's going to more
funding them for Education refund them
or Purge it yeah get rid of all these
[__] yeah so you have the blue Veil
right that people know about yeah it's
crazy what's pretty cool is uh did you
see recently they uh they locked up 40
of the sheriff's department uh games
yeah we locked them up yeah wow like and
they're exposing their tattoos and
everything it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool right pretty cool oh my God that is
cool [__] drain it yeah perch the
dirty cops yeah more psych training
probably more better strategies of like
well and get more people on the street
because at least in La like
before all of this happened there just
weren't enough I mean there's too many
people there's too many of us yeah not
me anymore but of you guys we gotta
upskill these cops no Mexicans yeah
we're everywhere bro we're everywhere
we're [__] taking over us
I get profiled all the time more than
you guys because as someone that has
kind of like been on both sides a little
bit like when I was a teen I was a
criminal and I've been hassled so I
understand the like defund the police
sentiment and I understand the police
brutality sense because I've been like
your brother but you look the
on the ground I've been put on my knees
I've been like you know racially
profiled especially in Monterey Park
where they have Asian gang units because
that's specifically what they're
targeting for yeah
so I've been on that side and having
even been on that side if I was 16 and I
heard that they're gonna defund the
police I'm gonna be like [__] yeah if I
Rob the house a day I'm gonna do two or
three now you know I mean so I'm like
this is [__] crazy so even for my
Criminal Mind I'm like do you guys see
where this is gonna lead no but then
yeah they did it
jazz or something yeah oh yeah like
Seattle or no that was like Washington
yeah and then and then even they became
the police do you remember that yeah so
they ended up making police of their own
that were just made of their own
citizens while they were doing it
they're like this job's [__] hard
well then there was footage there was
footage of those guys even abusing it
yeah of course there was footage of
those appointed like non-police cops
like actually bullying other people well
there's that study right that happened
like years ago where they had regular
people like Regular civilians they put
them in the jail system not in the
actual justice but they put him in jails
and they said okay you have you guys are
the prisoners you have you guys are
gonna play the cops and then after a
certain period of time the cops started
abusing interviewing the prisoners yeah
as you should
Howard what are you gonna do with it
foreign